hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
when my readers k who has a problem with
her sales process so I'll read the email
that she wrote it d repin thank you for
the great emails that you're always
sends me it helps with my business I
highly appreciate them they're really
helpful I'm kindly requests in your help
I have a huge problem with prospects we
always put through a presentation and I
could sense and see the deal is closed
or sometimes even tell me that there one
over the next thing when I look win to
give me the silent treatment they no
longer want to go ahead with the deal
and the worst part is they don't inform
me that just keep quiet what do i do I
call them back when email them follow up
or what I don't want to see my with the
desperate selfish sales person who only
thinks about myself and getting the cash
please help your assistance will be
highly appreciated kind regards k so
can't couple ideas for you the first
thing I would do is try to figure out
why they're saying no and I would go to
some of the prospects that you had maybe
a better connection with and just ask
them nope I understand we're not going
to visit together that's fine it really
helped me if you could let me know no
what happened or why you know you're not
able to go ahead with the decision you
can try you want it over the phone you
can try doing it by email but seeing
genuine let them know that you know
you're not trying to get the sale you're
just trying to improve yourself and make
a better presentation for next time to
other customers and when you approach it
like that and they know that you're not
try to sell them use your the more open
to be able to give you that kind of
feedback I want to find out what is
something wrong with you or are they
just not buying your products or was a
price too high or is it too much
competition whatever it is you want to
find out the main reasons why people are
not you know what a good vibe from you
the second thing is you might want to
think about trying to do a better job of
qualifying people before you go in and
do a presentation a lot of times people
will sit through a presentation say yes
it's great yes that's great just because
they want to seem a
be able right you don't want to
disappoint you they don't want to kick
you out of their office they just can't
wait for you to leave but they're trying
to be nice so they'll look like they're
really into it and then not end up
making the deal so you might want to
qualify people before think about some
of the questions that you might be able
to ask find out if they buy your type of
product kind of they have a budget and
low those questions before you go in and
do a presentation so maybe that's done
by email maybe that's done by phone
maybe it's even done by person but
before you get into a long presentation
you want to try to prequalify some of
your your prospects so tap for me I'll
run a google glass of my groups and
these are entrepreneurs we get together
once a month but we talk about our
business and it's a paid membership
group and you have to be on the startup
stage be able to get it the group so
most businesses are at least three
hundred thousand to a million dollar a
year range trying to get to that next
step so if you're under a few hundred
thousand dollars then you're not gonna
be a good fit for the group love that
you know you're not a great person or
you might not have a great business it's
just that it's not a good fit for what I
sell right so I could meet with all
these people I can tell them all about
the benefits of it give them lots of
free advice but at the end of the day
you're not going to be able to be a good
client because they're not in that range
or if they can't afford to members your
feet again they might come out and meet
with me and say hey this is really great
but then Vienna they don't have that
budget so before I go away and spend a
lot of time meeting with people I'll
always try to prequalify them i'll check
out their website I'll you know ask them
if they look too small what their
revenues are I'll let them know about
the prices involved so that both of us
are wasting our time right you don't
want to waste your time doing the
presentation and customers don't want to
waste their time sitting through
something that's not going to be of
interest to them so try to prequalify as
much as you can the last thing that I
would think about is if if you found
that they are really committed and
they're saying they want to buy get some
kind of
commitment right there on the spot so
get an order on the spot even if it's a
small order get their commitment to want
to move forward especially if they told
you yeah I really like what you're doing
here don't leave that office without
having some kind of confirm there except
for what's going to happen and as much
as well so try to get them to decide so
I hope that helps ok so again I look at
calling up prospects who didn't far from
you and see you know what was the
problem try to get some feedback then I
would go and look at different ways to
qualify your prospect make sure that
they are actually interested in it and
they can afford and and they are the
right potential customer for you and
then at the end of the day or go back
and try to get that signed deal get some
equipment to want to move forward for
the next process so I hope that helps if
you guys liked the video please give it
a thumbs up below I'd also love that
your thoughts and feedback if you want
to leave a comment below this video and
stay tuned for the next episode